this but some of you actually may not
and I'm speaking for those who are
watching from the future right now I
know that the live stream has not
started just yet but I wanted to say
hello because I know this game it's
actually it looks older than it actually
is but I played this first about two
years ago and oddly enough I'm starting
the stream on time so that's why I'm
talking to you guys and I'm doing all
this stuff in the meantime but for now
I'm gonna talk about power drill
massacre while I'm doing this because I
always meant to play it again I only
played it one time and then I always
said like this game was so cool and then
I was always intended to come back to it
and yet I didn't so here I am almost two
years later getting back into the game
and it's been updated I mean it's not
fully released yet apparently I don't
even know if the development has been
halted at all but this was always a
really cool game just in the way that it
was very very retro it was a super super
retro game and that kind of led it to be
this super super weird really
interesting game and hello everybody who
is watching me live now so hello hello
hello how are you guys doing welcome to
power drill massacre now I'm gonna go
ahead and start the game here just
making sure that everything is
hunky-dory on the stream front yes hello
hi can you see me tell me if you guys
can see me yeah
I'm not late I'm not late at all what
are you guys talking about I'm right on
time so anyway so we're gonna get going
here we've got a lot to work on and
we've got a lot to do so I'm going to go
ahead and get in the game here and start
a new one because if you guys remember
this ah things don't go so well if you
recall when we're in this environment
here things don't go oh hell there's
everybody hi how you doing everybody
it's very important plot yeah but if you
remember this doesn't go so well from
the very GetGo but I always loved the
retro styling of it like the VHS look to
it
it just it kind of it kind of set the
tone for the old 80 style horror movie
the
very campy you know cliche ridden but
still murderous gorian bloody murder
scene that was here and all what a
beautiful painted sunset that is huh
uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh
how old am i 27 aah crash alrighty then
as you can see not a good start to this
adventure but allow us to go even
further down into the depths of
depravity Jeff my name your name and
Jeff are you ok oh I can't I can't name
him my legs
don't worry Jeff I'll gonna get help
yeah I'm sure I'm gonna do that I don't
remember if that plot was there in the
beginning I only loaded is this up just
a test this is the worst headache ever
yeah the death headache from a car crash
but I think I'm alright it's getting
dark better get the flashlight out of
the trunk alright so the way this camera
oh oh
it's Jeff in there Jeff how you doing in
there Jeff Jeff just looks like a
mangled corpse I think Jeff is gonna
make it here alright so the camera is
just the tiniest bit wonky here so let
me just see if I can yeah how do I my
flashlight pick it up yeah let's go
ahead with yes all right so the used
button is spaced oddly enough ah there
we go if any of you remember this this
is bringing back any memories for you
guys oh yeah don't worry my name is Jeff
I want to come back for you oh oh oh boy
hi that's my name I was never married
that was right
the good old somber tones of the
orchestra so we're not doing the UM
we're not doing the the the fixed
orbital camera for this one just because
I remember trying to do that and just
navigating was always just a bit of a
bear anyway we're gonna skedaddle over
here I can't remember if there was a
stamina bar for running but I never made
it very far I'm just gonna go ahead and
say that right now if you didn't see the
first time I played this which if you
did I recommend watching it it was an
extremely scary game back in the day and
I if they've met any improvements to it
it's still extremely scary for how like
you guys who have never seen this before
probably that mark were you talking
about this looks like Garbo no you don't
know you have no idea what you're in for
oh but I do I know exactly what you're
in for
and we got to make our way over here I
need the help of my name's Jeff I gotta
help him in Jeff it's the only way to
get help is to Walker all along this
whoa wait what is that and I don't know
if that was that bad there before I
can't remember that anyway just walking
along this narrow sheer cliffs edge and
just hope for the best is you Korean off
into the depth what a creepy old shed
it's boarded up yeah creepy and old just
like everything here huh Oh
satanic symbol looks like some kids drew
a pentagram back here yeah some kids on
the creepy shed in the middle of nowhere
where you're definitely not gonna get
married rude all right so everybody if
you haven't already turned down your
lights crank up the volume too high
because we're about to make our way to
the manor of murder power drill massacre
nests so cuddle up in your blanket who
you think it'll help you which probably
won't considering all the murder that's
about to happen oh oh oh the signals
getting interrupted I mean I always
appreciated this retro styling for these
games actually um the game Friday the
13th is going to
coming out very soon which is Jason
Vorhees in all of his glory so I don't
know I think it doesn't have like a
multiplayer only type game which is
unfortunate if it is but I still kind of
want to play hi hello what a nice
warehouse you've managed to park up on
old high up there who's there I see you
hello okay goodbye then fare thee well
all right so if I recall correctly I
think this one is very defunct not that
I even know how this is just a junk car
nothing interesting inside but how did
it get up here I had to walk up a sheer
mountain cliff to get up here you just
wandered up the side path I don't think
any of these doors actually work I think
these are all just Garbo trickster doors
I can't use this door it's rusted shut
yeah you're not struck bing-bong let's
tour a sealed shut not rusted sealed and
I don't think I can go that way so oh
that's beautiful though so I'm gonna go
oops
into that bush and then I'm gonna go in
here and then I'm gonna die I'm hesitant
because I know how badly I'm going to
die I know how extremely I'm going to
die I know how excessively death is
going to approach me oh boy yeah
you guys good you guys good over there
yeah you guys good okay you don't have a
blanket well tough ship for you I guess
you're about to get your go about to get
unprotected when it comes to all these
horrors with which you have never seen
it alright
hello this door is open go inside yeah
sure why not you know what a creepy
building but why not maybe they got a
phone hi Oh Oh God Jesus that I okay so
so uh if you guys recall I am
immediately in danger from the second I
step in this building I'm immediate
in danger because you see that rolling
shutter you know what I'm not gonna
spoil it for you guys because things is
about to go down and oh man I don't even
know why it took me so long to play this
game again it kind of like it was one of
those games where I played it I loved it
it was amazingly horrifying and then I
just didn't play it again and I don't
know why oh hello are you important
looks like an article ripped out of a
newspaper read it the search continues
for two missing campers in the Pocono
Mountains Mason see Sargent and Lori
summers of Long Island New York have
been missing since June 8th their
campsite belongings have located but
investigators have few leads police say
there are no visible signs of a struggle
in this continues to be a rescue mission
the rest is missing dated August 1982
five years ago oh yes indeed looks like
a key pick it up yep you got a key with
blue plates better paint splattered on
it oh it's about to be a lot of red
paint splattered on the walls if I ain't
gonna be able to get away from the guy
that's in here so in case you're curious
um there's a reason it's called power
drill massacre
oh no we're we're aware vaguely vaguely
remember the layout of this place just
barely remember the layout of this place
it's not it's not entirely user-friendly
in terms of the navigation of here but
uh doing my best
doing the best guys
I can't remember if those sounds are
actually him or what uh uh uh
hello hi hello hi anybody here no okay
so I'm looking for I'm looking for a
door oh I forgot that just looped over
there I'm looking for a door I got to
stay clear of those blue shuttered doors
because that's bad news but I'm looking
for a blue door and I don't remember
where it is this place is much bigger
than you think
is that bad sign that bad time
yah yah yah yah yah yah yah yah yah yah
yah yah sugar tunnel oh don't go in the
sugar tunnel I forgot about the sugar
tunnel you don't want to go in the sugar
tunnel the sugar tunnel is bad news
Bubba bad bad news oh boy death death ha
ha what the [ __ ] I ran the wrong way ran
the wrong way ran right into a dead end
I did that's not good ok so anyway I uh
yes so I I got drilled I got drilled
yeah real easy that's um that's what
this games through this games all about
that's the only warning you get
footsteps and you're dead and you are
dead and unfortunately the blue key
spawns in random locations so I've
already read this so I just wanted to
read again ah [ __ ] it's like the owl
from Zelda okay so yeah that's all you
get that's all you get that's all you
get guys that's all you get oh you want
to see what's in the sugar top you guys
want to see what's in the sugar tunnel
oh oh you don't you really don't but you
know what I don't even know if I can get
in the sugar tunnel but sure why not you
know you guys are just so eager beaver's
about it we're gonna go down
into the sugar tunnel and you guys are
gonna Cleo I don't want to go in the
sugar tunnel the sugar tuplets an
unfriendly unforgiving place of death oh
[Music]
[ __ ] oh boy oh no wait that's not the
right way this is the right way oh I
forgot there's an upstairs I think I
need to go up there but up first let's
join I don't remember that being there
did you guys see that do you guys see
that or will it what am I just going out
of my mind or did you guys see a little
kid just run by well they probably just
came from the sugar tunnel so here we go
into the sewer tunnel
dude dude oh where is it
I forget forget where it is as I said
yeah this is this is it oh this is the
sugar tunnel oh boy oh gosh now here we
go we're now the sugar tunnel I don't
want to be here oh I don't want to be oh
that's a dead end
oh oh oh what was that what did I just
see uh-uh oh and I just saw I'm good
mm-hmm stop that you stop it you stop
that right now with those flashing this
the [ __ ] was it stop it no don't do that
no no no no aah
he's right baby no oh okay
all right ah I vaguely remember this I
vaguely vaguely remember this I vaguely
remember this oh no oh no oh no it was
goddamn Lube
oh yeah I think that's a place where you
can lose him if he's chasing you in the
sugar tunnels which is a good idea I
mean it's a bad idea in general to be
down here in the first place but you
know what did I see something bye
stop that no flashes no flashes here oh
okay
I think I might have made it out of here
stop that
ah no nothing the sugar tunnel no no no
no oh no is this toxic slime lovely no
no no no no no no no no no laughs oh god
oh god oh god oh god oh god I don't know
where I am
oh god it's a kid's room of yes No
what what Oh No all right no no no no no
no no no no I don't know what happened
did you kidnap me oh hi
okay oh okay goodbye then what in the
world has happened to me no you stop
that that is not okay that's not okay
[Music]
oh yes
right but that was the end i somehow
reached vending what how
happened dude
I don't even know I don't even know what
happened I don't even know what happened
that was messed up those messed up those
messed up but I know that's not the end
of the game cuz there's other things you
can do thinking but oh my god
yeah sorry everybody's ears but oh man
that's messed up alright let's try this
again
alright hang on I gotta oh okay she
comes all right start loading the game
up see that's gonna go anywhere
no oh oh there's no there's no game to
load anymore oh I gotta start over again
well [ __ ] then alright I'll go back into
it the man so the secret of that is uh
don't go in the goddamn sugar tunnels
and that's why hey don't go in there
it's a horrible place it's a horrible
place of death destruction for everybody
to see it's awful it's awful so [ __ ]
weird Oh goddamn it
oh thank you Kevin B who said hi mark I
just wanted to say what an inspiration
you've been to me your videos and your
words have got me through the hardest
times in my life yesterday was my
birthday and I'm so glad I'm getting to
watch you play this now well happy
birthday Kevin and happy birthday to
everybody out there what better way to
spend your birthday then a car crash
that leads you to go into a manner of
death and dismemberment that's a good
way to spend a birthday in my book so
I'm gonna rush back to the place and
hopefully hopefully I'm not gonna go in
the shirt
soon because I think the sugar tunnels
are just kind of bad for my overall
health hi my name is Jeff lean am at
Jeff I'm gonna help you Jeff please oh
god I werewolf where am I all right
there you go let's skedaddle back as
soon as that turns a light clears out of
my goddamn face here all right skedaddle
adieu skidooed lead ooh I'm schooling a
duel a little well then
ah that's much better I can see finally
the Ducks will keep me safe I don't
think those Ducks are gonna be able to
stop the power drill massacre murderer
Oh
a wipeout for triple a power drill seems
like just absolutely unnecessary for
this endeavor and I know also I wanted
to point out that this person has made
whoever's the developer this one is
maybe I can use the building in the
distance like whoever made this they've
made other games like this I don't think
I've played them though I can't remember
if I have or not but they've made other
games like this and this was the most
recent one and other than that I can't
remember if there was any more progress
to be made on that but I wanted to say
to the developer this is awesome like
you got to keep doing this like these
these as low res and as low graphics as
it is it still captures the good
terrifying claustrophobic gameplay of it
and just the messed up brutal nature of
it all like that's good and you should
keep doing that because like it's
sometimes hard to capture that feeling
of Terror and like just utter
helplessness and this game captures it
very well and so it may not be great in
terms of graphical fidelity but in terms
of Lee utilizing the graphics to tell a
story of the time that it's made in and
also using the VHS like overlays and
whatnot to emphasize that and also
cranking up the audio of it and making
the audio very good because even here in
the ambiance and you don't notice it
because it's good
but you hear like the wind whistling
whistling through and like the the the
crickets and the stuff it all sets a
tone for this time line in the game and
the horror of it and I really do
appreciate it I know I know it's
sometimes hard to get that across but I
really do appreciate it so we're back in
here so hopefully that blue keys going
to be there okay
or I'm gonna bug the game and go into
the building the wrong way everybody
hold on there everybody hold on to your
hats I don't know I think I transcended
reality there for a second well let's
try it again shall we
sure buddy boo boo buddy - can I go in
there alright this door is open go
inside yeah sure all right so other than
that ah come on
let's see all right here we go
so clickety click click okay that's fine
don't know who did that but good for
them
I think I just remembered running in the
halls is bad news but also it seems like
this guy is already chasing someone
through these halls and there's no good
there's no good that's so unfair
okay but it looks like the blue key
might be here
you got a key with green paint
splattered on it so I don't remember
where the green door was I dunno I need
to take it a little more cautiously
around here because I don't remember how
to get away from him I don't even know I
don't even remote oh I forget that they
change something is there like I can't
remember there's a way cuz I've gotten
pretty far in this game I don't think
there's like ah there's no hiding
mechanic there's no creeping mechanic
there's no you can just walk and hope
for the best the keys not there anymore
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh
boy I don't go in the sugar Tuttle I
don't want to go Oh Boyle all right this
isn't the sugar tunnel right there I'm
just going to travel through this area
okay I don't remember I don't like those
footsteps I'm Aaron
oh that's open yeah that's right that's
shutters open that's how you get in the
sugar tunnel you don't want to go in
there not again not again okay but there
should be something else here should be
summer I remember there's like a stairs
up that I can go to yeah here and
there's something up there I believe oh
no I think I'm I think me running is
what Skyy living thing me running ah I
think me running is what's doing it bad
how much blood
how much blood do I possibly have in me
how much blood could I possibly have in
my body I don't know but I don't think
it's enough all right let's try this
once more or at least a couple more
times before I give up on it
okay this time I'm just gonna walk I'm
not gonna try can I hide in these now
these are vending machines I can tighten
those but I can remember there's some
way some way to survive this because it
can't just be running I know it's not
just running I know there's something to
this some trick something
because you can get the keys you can get
the keys and get something here another
newspaper article Pocono vanishings no
trace of missing campers since 1978 12
campers have disappeared over a 100 mile
stretch of the Pocono Mountains we
conduct dozens of rescue missions each
year says Park Ranger Charlie plunk
people come up here to camp and hike all
the time without any experience
accidents happen
while most refuse rescues are successful
these 12 as stumped park rangers and
local police campfires left burning
boots and jackets left behind radio
still planning it's like these people
were ripped from their campsite says Abe
Bradley who is involved in the search
for I can't read anymore the ink has
faded okay so that's like this story and
I've never really been able to piece
together the whole story here it's like
some kind of also I mean it's one this
one murderer yes very much so but also
there's more to it than that
there's like there's like yeah there's
like oh I hate walking by those shutters
I hate it there's like um some sort of
like you remember the what is it the de
l'eau V passage didn't like
hi the the Russian incident where the
campsite was just left completely that
me that's me oh my god Jesus and scared
the piss out of me
right stop stop stop stop stop stop I
don't have time for you Jesus okay so
yeah this can't this this door is locked
there are three locks with splotches of
paint I don't think I've ever managed to
get all three keys to be able to unlock
that door but there is something else
around here I can't remember what I
think if I go down there's like a
basement yeah it's open so there's a
basement not that it's good to go in the
basement but it does exist yeah oh hi
okay we're getting the flashes again
down here
good great right great googly-moogly
who's this like this I think I remember
this I don't know oh boy was that hello
there's no tucked in the corner read it
my name is David Ashford my address is
365 six Coburn Massachusetts I think I'm
gonna die here I'm hiding this note hope
somebody will uncover it and know the
truth about what happened to us somebody
came to our campsite in the middle of
the night and doesn't seem like the note
was finished yeah I wonder why
I wonder why I wasn't finished I wonder
why that could have possibly been my
game now
[Applause]
okay anyway I think I think that might
be the end of what what I got going on
here I ran out of ran out of time I only
wanted a short little adventure into
this but look
power drill massacre it's a really tough
game it's tough stuff game tough game
for tough people but I'm not tough
enough so thank you everybody so much
for watching hope you enjoyed this
little stream hope you enjoyed me dying
horribly over and over and over again
that was always fun let me know how I
didn't end accountable thanks again and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye bye okay bye bye bye bye
bye bye bye